karine béchet golovkov merci de nous
avoir rejoints sur l'antenne de la
matinale de rtl france alors l'ukraine
refuse donc un de se tourner vers la
russie pour commander des vaccins
le vaccin est ce que c'est devenu une
arme politique
bonjour effectivement est d'ailleurs
angela merkel l'a parfaitement souligné
les pays se souviendront de ceux qui les
ont aidés autrement dit les pays font le
choix de savoir avec qui il va l'être et
dans quel camp l'ukraine est d'ailleurs
habitués à ce genre de négociations
puisque pour les mêmes raisons elle
préfère le gaz démocratique plus cher
venant des états unis où rivère sein de
l'union européenne et rejette le gaz
russe naturel à côté et moins cher donc
elle a la même politique mais ici quand
même suppose une question qui est
beaucoup plus grave parce que soi
zielinski ne croit pas à la pandémie et
dans ce cas là effectivement peu importe
on peut attendre un mois deux mois six
mois soit ils croient à la pandémie et
dans ce cas là le fait de rejeter a
priori la possibilité d'un vaccin russe
qui en tout cas actuellement
fonctionnent contrairement aux vaccins
paillard qui est absolument inefficace
pour une population de plus de 65 ans
qui sont les principales populations
touchées par le co lead dans ce cas là
c'est un acte de trahison
reste à prouver on n'a pas encore les
résultats et si oui lui disons qu'il ya
eu pas mal sur les deux publications là
qui ont commencé à sortir notamment en
occident qui remettent en cause la
l'efficacité qui part d'une efficacité
autour de 10% qui ont en tout cas ya des
questions qui se pose alors est ce
concernant concernant l'ukraine vous
disiez que le président hélène ski pour
probablement ne crois pas la pandémie or
on a vu quand même nom dans son
entourage
au niveau des idées aux représentants
des personnalités politiques elles se
sont fournis en vaccins c'est quoi c'est
une question de corruption
effectivement je dis pas qu'ils y
croient pas juridique
il faudrait qu'ils fassent un choix
parce que ça il n'y croit pas ça c'est
de la trahison
en ce qui concerne c'est ses
collaborateurs il y à des bruits ça non
plus ça n'est pas prouvée disant qu'un
avion
elle aurait fourni quelques doses à
certains députés notamment pour un peu
plus de 1000 rodado je crois que ce qui
a provoqué un certain scandale donc nous
sommes face à un état qui est en
faillite totale donc est incapable de
gérer une crise sanitaire ça c'est
évident et le fait derrière d'accuser la
russie que le fait notamment aussi le
département d'état qu'ils ont la russie
d'utiliser le coc vide pour porter à
sainte-thérèse souveraineté ukrainienne
est complètement dégagé les situations
l'ukraine elle même a mis complètement à
terre son système de santé et comment
cette position craignent elles étaient
l'observé depuis moscou la russie
finalement je serai prête à fournir ces
vaccins la russie a proposé déjà son
aide d'ailleurs l'ukraine avait commencé
des procédures d'enregistrement des
vaccins russe
zielinski à pousser des hauts cris en
disant qu'on ne traite pas avec l'ennemi
et du coup la population ukrainienne
restent sans couverture médicale
donc la russie regarde on va dire avec
un certain apitoiement mais une certaine
habitude puisque quand je dis ça n'est
pas la première fois que l'ukraine prend
sa population en otage elle l'avait déjà
fait avec le gaz et amis après le maïdan
sa population dans une situation de sous
approvisionnement qui avait conduit à
des fermetures en hiver de deux
d'établissements publics parce qu'il ne
pouvait pas être chauffée comment est ce
que les ukrainiens perçoivent cette
attitude des occidentaux qui sont assez
prompte finalement à soutenir les
oppositions lorsqu'il s'agit de de se
confronter à la russie
et qui finalement sont totalement
absents quand il s'agit de venir en aide
véritablement sur le plan de la santé
il me semble que l'on retrouve en tout
cas lorsqu'on lit la presse
cette dualité delà de la société
accompagnée d'une certaine fatigue c'est
à dire que la société qui qui reste en
quelque sorte plus rationnel le comprend
à ce moment pas du tout pourquoi on ne
peut pas se fournir du vaccin russe
qu'est ce que ça change
un vaccin est là pour soigner ça n'est
pas une arme chimique et la partie qui
est plus pro globaliste elle même et on
va dire assez fatigué aussi parce que
les slogans c'est très bien mais ça ne
règle pas les problèmes
le crâne qui va bénéficier néanmoins
dieu du programme cots vaccin qui est
destinée justement aux pays qui ne
peuvent pas se fournir en vaccins mais
c'est largement insuffisant alors juste
ça aussi c'est extrêmement significatif
le fait que l'ukraine soit obligé de
s'adresser à l'onu pour pouvoir
bénéficier du programme kowalski a
priori n'est quand même pas prévu pour
les pays situés en europe parce que même
s'il m'a si l'ukraine ne fait pas partie
de l'union européenne c'est un pays jeu
pratiquement européen montre à quel
point la maidan a complètement
déstructuré les institutions étatiques
ukrainienne qui sont totalement à
capable de gérer la situation
par ailleurs cela montre aussi que
l'union européenne à laquelle il un ski
s'est adressé en demandant qu'ils aident
à en fournissant des doses de vaccin est
elle même également absolument
incapables d'intervenir c'est à dire que
healy a d'un côté une grande énergie
pour soutenir et déstabiliser les pays
mais il n'ya strictement ni volonté
politique ni capacité politique ensuite
à construire une société qui sont
stables qui soit capable d'assumer et de
bizernig population et qu'est ce qu'on
sait aujourd'hui karine bechet de love
codes de la situation sanitaire en
ukraine
elle est semble-t-il assez précaire
sachant que le système de santé
ukrainien a été depuis la chute de
l'union soviétique laissée à l'abandon
et après le maiden en 2014
dans le premier gouvernement l'un des
ministres qui s'est occupé la réforme de
la santé est celui qu'ils avaient déjà
travaillé à sa d'escrocs à sa
description dans son pays d'origine en
georges donc si vous voulez c'est un
système qui est complètement à bout de
souffle qui a été laissée complètement
au privé et nous voyons ici le résultat
lorsque l'état privatise au lieu de
garder le contrôle c'est à dire que nous
sommes face à une logique de marché les
plus forts sion vivent ceux qui ont les
moyens survivants en revanche il n'y a
plus aucune prise en considération d'un
puits la possibilité de prise en
considération de l'intérêt public
merci beaucoup calmé chez call of code
avoir répondu ce matin en direct à nos
questions sur rt france merci